[Music]
[Music]
little town
it's a quiet village every day
like the one before little time people
waking up to say
[Music]
Vanja
there goes the Baker with his tray life
wait the steam room bradden lost your
son every morning just a stage since the
warning that wake hey morning Belle
opening Monsieur Jean how do you love
something again well I believe I have
problem is I can't remember what well
I'm sure it'll come to me
where are you off to - returns book -
peril bear it's about two lovers in fair
Verona sounds boring
[Music]
he's a distracted conscience hell
give a hotdog and be proud for the heads
up on some County tonight she's a funny
girl emotion good day how is your family
bozhe good day how is so white I need
six eggs has to expend see
ah if it isn't the only bookworm in town
so where did you run off to this week
two cities in northern Italy I didn't
want to come back are you got any new
places to go I'm afraid not
but you may read any of the old ones
that you'd like thank you your library
makes a small corner of the world feel
big on by Orange by the beshi because
the girl is so filled up I wonder if
she's feeling well over wine with a
dreamy far-off look then nose stuck in a
book but a parcel to the rest of us
it's my favorite you'll see
when she
she won't discover
it's him till Chapter three
now it's no wonder that her name means
beauty her looks have got no parallel
but behind a feather son I'm afraid
she's rather odd very different from the
rest oboe he's nothing like the rest of
us look at Halle fool my future wife
Belle is the most beautiful girl in a
village that makes her the best
but she's so well-read and you're so
athletically inclined I know alchemy is
argumentative or she is beautiful
exactly you'll meet her when you got us
yes but ever since the war I felt like
I've been missing something she's the
only girl gives me that sense of genetic
one I don't know what that means right
from the moment when I've met her saw
her I said she's gorgeous and I fell
here in town there's only she who is
beautiful as me so I'm making plans to
move
[Music]
[Music]
it's never gonna happen ladies
[Music]
to pull this baby now c10 young
excuse me I'll get the nice fish hey
smell
I'm going to me
so almost a few mama
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Disney's Beauty and the Beast on blu-ray
and Digital June 6th if she is the one
will break the spell you must finally
learn to love what is it Rick
[Music]
will you join me for dinner
[Music]
it's outrageously attractive isn't it
it's wonderful if you like it so much
than it's yours
don't
Disney's Beauty and the Beast on blu-ray
in digital June 6th
[Music]
you
[Music]